lots to talk about then uh with the
conservative party co-chair joins us now
mr dowden how's the new job going very
well thank you delighted to be on here
with you yeah time to have a holiday uh
no certainly not since i was uh
appointed chair of the conservative
party um talk about delays at felix
stowe um apparently a third of uk
freight
comes through felix still what's the
problem
well first of all it is worth noting i
believe that felix stokeport authorities
have said this morning that the
situation is improving which is welcome
news there is though clearly a
challenging problem particularly with
hgv drivers and not just here it's
across europe poland us even china has
this challenge that's why we've been
taking steps to address it whether it is
for example with more training 5000 more
places for for training hgv drivers
making the process more flexible we're
working through these challenges to
address them and i i know that it's a
difficult and worrying time for for your
viewers and they'll be concerned by
these reports but i want to assure them
and assure you that the government is
very much seized of these challenges and
is getting on with the job of addressing
them
that 5 000 european drivers um how's
that going
well so there's there's two separate
elements so there's 5 000 more
uh training so so getting more people
trained within the uk more more places
than training and then there's the
further 5 000 visas up in the run-up to
christmas that we've been whether we've
made available i don't have the the
latest numbers to hand for it
27.
well i i'm we may have more updated
numbers than that now it's not going to
be in the hundreds though is that well
it is it is one part of a range of
measures that we are taking so it's not
that is not the only sort of um
thing upon which we're disappointing
there
well i'm sure we'll get more more
numbers as as time goes on but that's
why we're not just relying and it's
really important that we don't just rely
on
importing labour as we have done in the
past we also need to make sure we train
up people here in the uk that's why
we're putting the extra resources into
training people up in the uk that's why
i'm making the process better and more
streamlined so there's a range of
measures and it's all about this wider
point which is that we need to get the
skills here have those higher paid jobs
and actually the latest news just
yesterday about increases in wages is a
real example of how that that strategy
is working but the short term impact is
that toys are being turned away for
christmas
well the the situation is uh improving
i'm confident that people will be able
to get their their toys for for
christmas as i say i quite understand
why people are concerned by these
headlines but we are working through
these challenges as we have worked
through other challenges so should
people buy now for christmas just to be
on the social side i think it's sensible
to to buy when you want some people buy
very early for christmas my wife is
quite an early christmas buyer me too
others buy later i would say just just
buy as as you do normally so for all the
kids watching um obviously father
christmas will be fine and he'll have
everything yes i have i have i have
children myself and uh they they can be
there you go dad's reassuring you this
morning kids all's going to be well um
the eu instead let's talk about that the
northern ireland protocol um lots of um
eu concessions we're going to hear more
about that but it's been heavily leaked
in the papers today i'm sure you're well
aware um are the concessions that
they're coming up with enough
well clearly we will we'll wait to
receive the the full um announcement
from the eu uh and i know that lord
frost says he said yesterday
and the government as a whole will
engage
fully constructively with these
proposals
uh it is important that there is
fundamental change to the the northern
ireland protocol so we'll be looking to
see that but let's see exactly what the
eu comes up with well apparently they
are going to offer a chill to remove a
majority of the post-brexit checks on
british goods up to 50
of customs checks on goods will be
lifted more than half of the checks on
meat and plants entering northern
ireland would be abandoned under the new
concessions would that be enough well
those are welcome steps and we will we
will look at them and engage properly
with them but we do need to have a
proper
uh discussion about this because i think
there are wider questions particularly
in relation to the competence of the the
european court what used to be the ecj
the cgeu
it is a rather anomalous position
whereby this treaty almost uniquely is
governed by the courts of one party to
it but we knew that already
yes we we we knew that and we didn't
highlight it until recently um well well
we knew that originally but i think two
things have have changed uh since then
first of all that was agreed without
knowing what the wider trade
relationship would be with the eu now we
have got a comprehensive trade
arrangement with them and secondly it is
clear that
uh in northern ireland and particularly
in in one community in northern ireland
the the northern ireland protocol is not
working and one of the challenges of
that is the fact that the the treaty is
governed by the courts of one of the
signatories so i think we do also need
to engage on that more fundamentally
what do we want that to look like who do
you want to oversee
well there's plenty and again i don't
want to preempt those uh discussions but
there are there are many many
international treaties that have uh
independent uh
uh courts and arbitrations uh mechanisms
for them that aren't don't belong to one
party or or the other and i think it's
appropriate that we should engage with
the eu to see how can we can resolve
that because in the end i think the uk
and the eu we surely are united in the
same position which is that we want to
maintain a stability in northern ireland
we want to ensure the continuity of the
belfast agreement and all the other all
the other progress that we've made and
there is a problem with this protocol at
the moment so is it a deal breaker if
the european uh court still has
oversight well it is a it is a major
issue for us and we want to engage them
i'm not going to start
preempting uh you know writing red lines
here here and there but uh i think
what uh lord frost said yesterday this
was a major issue and we we do it i mean
they've made a lot of concessions there
it would appear i'm sure that my viewers
would think uh the same but now you're
saying uh it can't be overseen by the
european court so it does sound as
though it's a red line well
i very much welcome what the said and we
will engage very constructively we'll go
through it in detail i don't know every
element of what the eu are proposing
we've seen some of these reports we also
made clear and lord frost made clear
yesterday consistent with the the
command paper we issued in july that we
also have a challenge with the the way
in which this uh treaty is governed that
the court that has jurisdiction over it
so we'd expect to engage with the eu on
that point as well some say that you are
negotiating we the uk is negotiating in
bad faith
no
quite quite the contrary indeed it has
always been the case that
uh
treaties and agreements are
up for disc further discussion and um
further agreement on the move you take
for example the juxtaposed controls uh
in relation to france outreach with with
france on border controls uh those have
been revised over time and then indeed i
believe the french
are seeking again to change those this
is perfectly normal that we should seek
to adapt and in the end what we want to
do is we want to make sure that we have
something that is enduring that works
for northern ireland and i think that's
a goal that surely both us and the eu
should share oh i'm glad you brought up
the french i hadn't thought about that
um speaking to one of your colleagues
last week about when we're going to give
them the money we owe them any clearer
on that
well we expect the french to to do their
part of the the bargain uh which means
are they not
well the the um home secretary has
raised concerns about that and i'm sure
the home secretary will be making sure
that that is done with if the french
keep up there so it's not us reneging on
another deal isn't it no it's not us
reneging on a deal at all it's making
sure that we
deliver on what uh was agreed originally
so we don't feel we're getting value for
money at the moment so we're not paying
them
well the the home secretary has uh
raised concerns about this with her
french opposite numbers and we very much
hope and would expect that we would make
payments as agreed but the french need
to keep up their side of the agreement
so your colleague said to me the other
day that um the payment would be going
through within a matter of weeks that's
not necessarily the case well we would
very much hope and expect that would be
the case but in return we'd expect the
french to keep up their side of the
agreement okay talk to me about this um
damning report that came out um
yesterday about the government's
handling of the pandemic just to check
first of all you have read it have you
yes of course i've seen you say of
course because of course uh yesterday
the minister hadn't read it um are you
happy to offer an apology to all of the
families who lost loved ones well the
the prime minister
apologized earlier this year for all the
the hurt and distress that her all those
families have suffered and i
i share that and of course i i offer
that as well it's been a terrible time
for every family affected by this this
terrible
um virus and by the way i welcome this
report as well i think it's a very good
report by um
by greg clark and by by jeremy hunt and
of course the government will as we do
with all these reports
be fully analyzing it and giving a full
response to to the report and all the
recommendations in there still looking
for the word sorry well
the prime minister said sorry and and
are you sorry yes of course i'm sorry as
the prime minister is sorry you i mean i
was just listening to the sort of
experiences
yesterday of those bereaved families and
that kind of terrible loss that they've
suffered and so many people have
suffered not just in this country but
around the world from the covert crisis
what are you sorry about
we're we're sorry for the the losses
that um that all those families have
suffered but also of course we accept
that and i i hope i think your viewers
would appreciate this as well that
during this covert crisis this was an
unprecedented crisis it's a once in a
hundred years um event
there isn't some perfect rule book that
that we could follow we are having to
adapt and move very quickly and of
course we would do some things
differently um with hindsight but also
as the report rightly says
with things like the vaccine programme
um we made huge progress and and at real
pace with it and mr chair i'm i'm
absolutely confident that my viewers you
know and you had a lot of support at the
time it was a once in a hundred years
global pandemic
but
do you appreciate that when ministers
sit there not you but your colleague
yesterday steve barkley sat there and 11
times he refused to apologize that means
that for my viewers that says
politicians are out of touch with the
rest of society well i i i i said
sometimes i'm happy to say again that i
i completely appreciate and understand
the
um the the hurt and the um
the pain that the
families up and down this country have
suffered as a result of
of covet it has been a terrible disease
and um we're still not fully through it
yeah but i i went on to develop the
point which was when ministers sit there
and won't apologize can you understand
that that viewers feel that they're not
in touch with their everyday concerns
well
i understand that that your viewers
want
ministers like me government ministers
to appreciate the the scale of
of what's happened and the hurt that
they feel and we we do and the prime
minister
has has acknowledged that and has has
said sorry for all the suffering that
people have and when your colleagues
refuse to apologize 11 times well well
steve said what what steve said um uh
yes then i i'm afraid i didn't read the
the full transcript of everything that
that um that was said in that particular
interview but the prime minister has
has been clear on that he should have
said sorry though
well the prime minister has uh has said
sorry i'm not going to start giving
running commentary on different
interviews that i didn't watch i didn't
know the future you can't watch the show
sadly
well thank you for joining us i watch
you many many times but sadly yesterday
yesterday morning i wasn't able to
to tune in okay well you can always
watch it back on youtube uh what about
uh your uh successor nadine doris saying
the bbc is impartial is not impartial
well i think this is one of the the big
challenges for the bbc and it's one of
the things i talked about a lot as
culture secretary with the uh bbc and i
very much um share nadine's sentiments
that i i love the bbc i genuinely do and
i think the bbc should um
though be a proper national institution
and reflect all parts of the country and
all different um perspectives and
therefore
in order to do that they have to be
impartial they have to reflect not just
the views in london and bristol and
brighton but also the views in dudley
and lee and
wolverhampton or um you know
the north of scotland that's
that is the role of the bbc to be a
genuine national broadcaster i think
they know that do you think they don't
fulfill that
i think they have acknowledged and if
you look at what tim davey has said
previously he's acknowledged there is a
challenge about making sure the bbc
represents all parts of the united
kingdom all different perspectives and i
think they acknowledge that there's
further to go and i would hope they
continue to do so and what about when
they interview your boss do you think
they're impartial then
uh i think the bbc needs to strive for
impartiality in all of did you see that
interviews i saw well i think there were
two interviews in question one talking
particularly about so i i saw some of
both the
the the mar interview and listen to some
of the uh nick robinson interviews you
might appreciate as chairman of the
the conservative party i was quite busy
during conference i i thought it was the
curious the way that um
the prime minister was told to stop
talking um but again
go on and on and on it has to be said
well i i'm not i'm not going to get into
the in the sort of the details of each
interview but i think as an overall
point of principle it is really
important that the bbc upholds
impartiality and there are challenges
yeah now i do need to let you go in just
a second but i just want to talk to you
about this report from the um
environment agency climate change will
cause more floods and droughts rising
sea levels and a greater demand for
water supplies that according to the
environment agency are we doing enough
to try to stop it
uh
we are but there's not much more to do
and this is why the the cop summit the
climate change summit in november is so
essential because
it can't just be the uk alone if we
stopped all our emissions tomorrow it
wouldn't solve climate change that's why
we have to get that international
agreement and the prime minister and
alex sharma who's our special
representative are making good progress
with that and i'm very hopeful that
we'll make progress at the summit but in
addition we need to do things in the uk
in the short run for example that's why
we're investing over five billion pounds
in flood defenses to protect communities
that will be affected before we can get
any wider climate change policies in
place congrats on the new job thanks for
finding the time to come join us
appreciate it